bonsoir donc j'ai travaillé la défense
mais peut-être pas exactement comme vous
croyez donc il ya deux ans je venais
régulièrement dans le quartier et je me
posais à la sortie du métro à 7 heures
le matin avec un grand panneau jaune sur
lequel il avait écrit souriez ça
pourrait changer votre journée alors
j'étais pas tout seul parce que à la
descente
le matin à 7 heures il ya aussi les gens
qui distribuent les prospectus
publicitaires 20 minutes
moi je me tenais un petit peu en retrait
histoire de pas laisser dire des gens je
voyais des gens qui sortaient du métro
qui se prenait une ruée de 20 minutes et
prospectus en faisant à la tête déjà
qu'ils faisaient un peu la tête parce
qu'ils allaient travailler et ensuite il
voyait mon panneau ici l'été un sourire
alors un matin un monsieur qui
distribuent des prospectus viens de voir
est dit excuse moi mais il ya un truc là
à temps ils sont tous en train de
sourire et à moins une fois la tête
alors je vous dis oui je suis bien
obligé de le reconnaître c'est pas juste
et me dit mais tu fais quoi avec
compagnie je ne dis pas je fais comme
toi je fais mon boulot je rends les gens
là je ne vois ouvrir des grands yeux un
espoir est inutile
ok alors c'est qui ton employeur et
contre ces pays la tête du monsieur
quand il a compris que j'avais pas
d'employeur et que j'étais payé 0
alors il est reparti tout penaud il se
dit que finalement ça avec eux mais j'ai
quand même envie de vous raconter ce qui
m'a mené là avec le fameux panneau jaune
parce que selon moi j'avais
plus beau salaire du monde c'était la
liberté d'être à ma place et de faire ce
que j'aime
un jour est arrivé dans le quotidien
professionnel où j'ai perdu le sens je
sais pas si vous voyez ce que je veux
alors peut-être pas encore ça viendra
pas toujours est il que je suis pas
malheureuse parce que je travaillais
dans le choix des entreprises mais je
trouvais que tout ça manquait de sens
pour eux j'ai compris que si je restais
au même endroit dans le même milieu avec
les mêmes règles mêmes présupposés
j'avais toujours tomber sur les mêmes
choses
alors j'ai décidé de déconnecter de tous
j'ai quitté mon job
mon appartement la ville dans laquelle
je me fais depuis presque toujours paris
et du même coup ma famille et mes amis
et je me suis lancé là raconte alors oui
on me dit mais comment tu vas faire
quand tu vas rencontrer si tu trouves
pas de job entre histoire allant trop
vous conseiller d'y sera gros comme ça
mais moi je crois que quand on a la
chance d'avoir fait les bonnes études on
a le devoir de pas croire à ce genre de
bêtises j'ai choisi deux destinations à
l'instinct berlin et lisbonne et j'ai
décidé d'aller vivre trois mois dans
chacune dans des colocations un peu
chiche et si jamais maquette faisait
sens après six mois je continue avec
voyage je suis dotée d'un projet donc
rendre les gens heureux
cette fois on m'a dit c'est a du boulot
mais j'ai dit c'est super parce que ce
que je sache c'est d'avoir vous et je me
suis dit je vais pas avoir de plan mais
d'objectifs
je vais naviguer à lens 1 en
expérimentant je voulais être libre et
que aurélie d'aujourd'hui n'entrave pas
la liberté de rémy demain
vous savez avec des objectifs
qui ne correspondrait plus et puis
j'avais compris que l'instinct est une
de nos plus grandes forces et qu' il
faut apprendre à l'écouté l'instinct de
partir déjà a été une des choses les
plus importantes alors que j'avais créé
un réseau croire à paris à tout point de
vue mais si jamais j'étais resté genre
et du 116 rassurer mes proches sur ce
que j'allais devenir ce que j'allais
faire mais moi même j'avais aucune idée
tout ça est évidemment j'étais inquiète
alors j'aurais été bien incapable de
rassurer que ça j'avais cherché dans ce
jeu dans ce voyage la solitude qui
permettrait de choisir veut trouver ma
voie mais pour autant je voulais pas
tomber dans le vide
vous savez ce vide qui me rend
apathiques incapables d'avancer vite
autrement a fait progressivement
oui ça faisait un peu peur alors un jour
j'étais allongé sur mon lit berlinois
tout péter et je regarde le plafond en
sachant pas qu'est ce que j'allais faire
par où commencer et qu'est ce que je
faisais là alors que je me disais que
j'aurais pu savoir j'aurais pu être à
paris dans une quotidien confortable
dans ces moments là je savais qu'il
fallait réagir parce que sinon c'est la
déprime ensuite c'est retour au bercail
à la case départ
et puis en plus encourageants d'une
étude en salle et c'est trop idéaliste
tu dois te contenter de sculpteur nude
aller chercher quelque chose qui
n'existe pas ok alors je me suis levé
n'est pas pour travailler non parce que
ça j'étais bien capable je me suis levé
pour faire rien mais faire comme je
m'étais promis
j'ai commencé à marcher et j'ai laissé
mes pas me disais et puis j'étais le
long du canal
j'ai commencé à regarder l'eau coule et
puis ensuite mouvant il faisait bouger
les branches des arbres et les signes
des grands signes d'un qui s'en
rendraient bien atterri 7
et là j'ai senti monter en moi une joie
j'ai compris que en connectant à la
nature je ne connais tu es à ma propre
joint à côté de la nature y avait aussi
des gens vers qui nous plonge a été
tourné en réalité je voulais donner aux
gens sans rien recevoir en retour et je
recevais énormément jallet par exemple
donc mon post est avec mon grand panneau
jaune dans les endroits où les gens me
font pression en vain de automatique
et là je vais voyez me sourire interagir
vous dire merci
en fait on nous raconte partout tout ce
qui nous déchire et la violence qu'il ya
entre les gens mais j'avais la preuve
que quelque chose d'aussi simple qu'un
sourire peut nous unir ces deux choses
c'est de lien à la nature et à notre
humanité qui nous permet de bien vivre
la solitude que je m'étais opposé plus
après six mois le projet se pérenniser
ordinary à duppigheim commencé à se
faire connaître
tu reviens réseaux sociaux et j'avais
des pistes de collaboration avec des
entreprises
mais vous vous souvenez seul instinct de
bidet et l'instant il me disais dans mon
nom n'y vais pas alors en attendant je
faisais des rencontres incroyables et un
jour une de ces rencontres nous dit et
si pour continuer son voyage tu pars
saisis dans un raid à aménager
je trouvais ça formidable humble avis
nager personnellement j'avais fait trois
fois du conflit demeure ma vie et je
connaissais pas du tout cet univers donc
jeudi
jeu sauf que cette fois d'un style made
in asie up alors vas-y et donc deux mois
plus tard j'ai embarqué dans un camion
aménagé un ancien que la même copie
rouspétant du nom de ramda s'était
c'était ma maison
là c'est une des plus belles périodes de
ma vie a commencé
moi je vais pas vous mentir tout n'était
pas rose par exemple mon piano et pas
très bien donc le soir où j'ai il avait
un petit rituel qui dure un peu plus
vite devenu un jeu pc la planche en bois
qui servait dit j'attrape et le matelas
clients 3 dans l'armoire que j'ai déplié
je mettais un bras dessous en dehors du
dessus une couverture de grand mère un
duvet résistance il m'a d'ailleurs une
autre couverture de grands moi même j'en
fais des confiseries des chaussettes de
ski un sweat à capuche un bonnet g rabat
et la capuche sur le bonnet on était
d'hébreu début avril 2016 et dans ramdam
la nuit il faisait 5 de la met à côté ça
qu'est-ce qui avait sauvé la vie
est il vraiment
j'ai trouvé une grande solidarité sur la
route
j'ai voyagé avec des gens que je venais
à peine de rencontrer
on m'a proposé d'aller prendre des
douches chez les uns et chez les autres
ont offert des légumes du jardin des
confitures faites maison à la framboise
et et on a même préparé des petits plats
chauds quand j'étais malade
en faisait passer à la parisienne et et
puis aussi j'étais au coeur de la nature
le soir avant de me coucher je regardais
des étoiles je ne crois pas que vous
finissiez parce qu'à paris y'a pas des
toiles mais voilà c'est qu'ils
souhaitent et le matin je parlais aux
oiseaux parce que ça fait vachement bien
de parler de ça maintenant
et puis quand je trouvais pas de douche
et ben c'est simple je veux sauter dans
la rivière
voilà avec mon shampoing savon et je
vous l'avais dans la région j'ai été au
coeur de la nature et j'avais jamais
vécu ça j'ai découvert à quel point elle
faisait du bien à quel point elle me
vider l'esprit et à quelle voie à une
m'éloigner de toutes les considérations
qui servent à rien de tout de tout les
doutes qu'on peut avoir toutes les idées
reçues
et puis de toutes les boucheries qu'on
peut voir à ce moment là mon projet
s'est arrêté j'ai fait une pause de
travail et j'ai juste vécu
et puis sans savoir trop ni comment ni
pourquoi j'ai commencé à écrire d'abord
tous les soirs et puis les après midi et
parfois de matin et puis même parfois
toute la journée parce que dans un dab
ou quand il pleuvait j'étais enfermé
dans l'es10 métal kg crédit et vous
savez ce que c'est mon rêve
quand j'avais 8 ans où il demandait des
jouets à mon grand père pour moi l'art
ça je lui demandais de me donner sa
machine à écrire et ensuite l'écriture
et moi on s'est un peu une ride la faute
peut-être vos commentaires de certains
proviseurs et puis parce qu'il fallait
que je me construis en affirmant depuis
que j'ai 20 ans j'ai essayé de retrouver
ce bien à l'écriture je vais aller dans
des cafés je me suis levé très tôt le
matin
j'ai acheté des bouquins mais c'est
toujours resté des petits bouts de
choses inabouti il a fallu que je nantes
par accabler n'y avait rien pour que je
retrouve tout alors j'ai vécu six mois
dans mon camion neuf mois
j'avais une autre moi je sais pas s'il
ya des célibataires dans la salle bon
moi j'ai été célibataire par un 10 ans
et quand je suis parti faire une
aventure on m'a dit bah dis donc c'est
pas comme ça que tu l'as trouvé un mec
on dit ça aussi
et en fait c'est comme ça que j'ai
trouvé un mec j'ai même rencontré
l'amour de ma vie
voilà
maintenant on vit ensemble dans la
campagne au milieu des vaches
ces prochaines est par ailleurs j'ai
créé un lieu un livre en entier avec
tout plein de paris est une histoire qui
tient de bout en bout cette histoire
c'est celle que j'ai vécue que je
raconte pour continuer à roncq des gens
là pour donner de l'élan pour pousser
les gens à aller vers quelque chose qui
leur ressemble
je me suis connecté à mon rêve d'enfant
mais parce que d'abord l'avait accepté
de me déconnecter
alors j'ai une petite question pour vous
ce soir
qu'est-ce qui se passerait dans votre
vie politique merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gouin ce point